قصف جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منزلا لعائله
الحاج في مخيم نصيرات وسط القطاع ما ادى
الى وقوع سبعه شهداء وعده جرحى وتدمير
المنزل استهداف منزل يعود لعائله الحج في
مخيم النصير اشتعال ليران في هذه اللحظات
بشكل م المنزل بالقرب من مسجد ابو داوود
في مخيم
النص عبي من ورا
عبد شويه
هذا المنزل المستهدف منزل عائله الحج الذي
قصفته مقاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه طواقم
الانقاظ الان و الافاء طواقم
الاسعاف حدث عن وجود عدد من
الشهداء قدش عدد اللي كانوا في البيت
تقريبا البنات النساء ثلاثه نعم وولدين
ولد طلع مع
ابوه محمد حبيب مم ش يعني هذه الحجه تتفقد
ابنائها واحفادها في هذا المنزل لا
الال
سالم هذا
هو مكان سقوط
الصاروخ في هذا
المنزل منزل عائله الحج المخير
الصيرات لا يزال البحث عن شهداء اطفال
تحت ركام هذا
المنزل الله يرح
نعم
اطفال قد قتلتهم مقاتلات الاحتلال الح لا
اله الا الله ايش عملوا هدول ايش ذنبهم يا
عالم حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي الله
ونعم
الوكيل قياس الار الانيه هد الحرائق
نتيجه قصف المقاتلات الحربيه في منزل
عائله الحج طواقم الانقاظ
الان تبحث عن مزيد من
الشهداء العالقين تحت رم هذا المنزل
انتشال شهداء
جدد شهداء جدد ال
انتشال من هذا
القص
هنا عدد من
الشهداء داخل هذه السياره سياره الاسعاف
ساعه زمن الا انا قمت على صوت
الانفجار وبطل
حوالي تحت يعني في ضربه بس الوسط كان قصف
قوي طلعت اجري نار فوق عن دار ولا دار
سلام طلعت فوق ما فيش حدا ما فيش حدا من
دار سلام الله يرحمكم يا يا اودي الله
يسهل عليكم يا اولادي الملتقى الجنه ان
شاء الله انتشالهم منزل عائله الحاج والذي
قصبته المقاتلات الحربيه قبل
قليل طواق الدفاع المدني بكافه تشكيلاتها
الفاض الاسعاف والاطفاء واجهت صعوبه في
انتشال الشهداء
طبعا اجساد الشهداء ممزقه اشلا
يعني يعني بالعافيه لما احنا لمينا
لم هذا هو المنزل
المستهدف قبل المقاتلات